[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález en glasgow
en escocia tiene lugar la copa 26 la
conferencia de las partes de la
convención de las naciones unidas sobre
el cambio climático considerada esta
como la última cumbre con oportunidades
reales para mantener el calentamiento
global en 15 grados centígrados por
encima de la temperatura media de la era
preindustrial el anfitrión el primer
ministro británico boris johnson dio un
inicio a este encuentro bastante
particular urgiendo a los más de 120
líderes a tomar acciones urgentes para
acabar con el consumo de carbón acelerar
la transición a vehículos eléctricos
detener la deforestación y también
elevar las contribuciones financieras de
los países en desarrollo el primer
británico advirtió que el cambio
climático está ocurriendo en este
momento y también recordó sobre el peso
que caerá sobre esta generación por no
actuar para revertir el daño ambiental
dijo textualmente nos juzgarán con
amargura eso fue lo que dijo el primer
ministro británico
el inicio de esta cumbre en escocia un
inicio directo concreto pero de la que
ya sabemos que no se hacen sino anuncios
concretos poco vinculantes y que los
gobiernos no priorizan prefieren seguir
dando relación al crecimiento económico
y el consumo descontrolado más detalles
en el siguiente reporte
desde el acuerdo de parís de 2015 el
objetivo de los países firmantes sigue
siendo el mismo limitar el calentamiento
global a 15 grados celsius para mediados
de siglo pero según una clasificación
del grupo de investigación climate
action tracker hasta la fecha solo un
país ha cumplido todos los criterios
para este objetivo cambia gracias a la
reforestación y a la energía solar este
pequeño país agrícola se está acercando
a los niveles de reducción de co2
deseados justo debajo de gambia en la
lista se encuentra la gran potencia
industrial reino unido- que obtiene una
clasificación de casi suficiente una
puntuación basada principalmente en sus
promesas pero otro grupo new carbon
brief dice que el país se está adaptando
rápidamente con londres a medio camino
de alcanzar su objetivo de cero
emisiones de carbono en 2050 para
climate action tracker marruecos costa
rica y etiopía y también están avanzando
en la dirección correcta según el mit
technology review francia ocupa la
cuarta posición entre los países más
verdes del mundo pero estos resultados
positivos se basan principalmente en los
gastos invertidos en una recuperación
verde como la producción de hidrógeno
mientras tanto las emisión medias de co2
en transporte y la agricultura son más
altas en francia que la mayoría de
naciones europeas el informe the mic
tech también señala que ucrania noruega
y suecia son los países que más
esfuerzos se están realizando para
reducir las emisiones de gases sin
embargo la política climática global de
esas tres naciones sigue considerándose
en gran medida insuficiente
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
marcelo mena director del centro de
acción climática de la pontificia
universidad católica de valparaíso él se
encuentra en la ciudad de glasgow en el
reino unido- también está con nosotros
maximiliano bello asesor de políticas
públicas oceánicas de misión blue
también se encuentra en la ciudad de
glasgow en escocia ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
del canal estamos en facebook en
instagram y en twitter síganos como
france24 bajo ese y arroba sant y luego
les recuerdo que la etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 comenzamos entonces en
preguntándole a marcelo mena allí en la
ciudad de glasgow sobre el inicio de
esta cumbre lo que se ha podido percibir
hoy en la inauguración en los discursos
iniciales en lo que están anunciando los
diferentes mandatarios los diferentes
organismos internacionales como es este
abrebocas de este inicio de esta
conferencia internacional
y pienso que partió
como ha sido usual en esta conferencia
discursos que suenan similares años
anteriores promesas de que se van a
tomar medidas en el futuro pero poca
acción concreta en lo local pero en lo
que respecta a la negociación como tal
hay esperanza yo he estado conversando
con los negociadores de chile con quien
me tocó trabajar con envío de ministros
y me comentan de que la adopción de la
agenda en forma unánime en el corto
plazo y propuestas concretas para los
temas que han sido quedado pendientes
con respecto a la regulación de la cob
25 en chile en españa pero en chile y
hay avance a lo que significa entonces
que el reino unido y su delegación ha
hecho el trabajo de anticipación para
poder negociar privadamente llegará a
una agenda que va a ser ejecutada más
eficientemente lo que se pensaba 12 por
tanto es toda una esperanza de que por
lo menos los compromisos de diplomáticos
su parte del reino unido
tan rindiendo fruto y esperemos que eso
signifique tener un resultado exitoso en
lo que respecta a la canacope lo que sí
está más al bebé y que probablemente al
terminar este año va a ser lo más cálido
de la historia con mayor daño climático
en lo que va todos lados el chile recién
terminó su mes de octubre más tarde su
historia registrada y por tanto tenemos
que seguir tomando mucha urgencia porque
si bien estaba avanzando la lucha contra
cambio climático los esfuerzos que
estamos haciendo son insuficientes
todavía para mitigar lo más lo más malo
maximiliano también allí en la ciudad de
glasgow en escocia sus impresiones
después de la inauguración de esta
cumbre yo ya daba alguna de las
impresiones que ha dado el primer
ministro británico como anfitrión de la
copa 26
y su connacional marcelo también daba
sus impresiones cuáles son las huellas
sí yo creo que hay una clara impresión
como hacía bien barceló de que hay una
repetición en los discursos que falta un
poco más de acción creo que queda claro
después de la vuelta de roma también del
g20 en el presente vaivén como también
el primer ministro cierto de johnson me
hicieron claro su de alguna forma su
frustración respecto de la poca ambición
se esperaba un mensaje mucho más claro
de la de esta de estos países altamente
desarrollados o cierto del g20 en traerá
algo a la mesa que fuera más concreto y
seguimos entonces con estos anuncios que
aplazan y aplazan llevamos ya muchos
años de discusión es cierto está el 26
sin embargo el tiempo se sigue por tanto
no no no no es que el tiempo se siga
alargando al contrario y en ese sentido
creo que es importante entender que lo
que estamos esperando son cuestiones
concretas para disminuir las emisiones
seis países son particularmente
importante como china india y otra no
maximiliano sigo con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa usted menciona que él
tiene se está acabando la fe de la
población internacional o de la
población mundial también se está
acabando en estas cumbres porque sigue
siendo importante llevarlas a cabo
cuando el accionar de los países es
tampoco los avances son tan pocos firman
el acuerdo de parís hace seis años y los
avances son muy pocos todavía buenos y
efectivamente éste era una arma una
copia importante porque había un
compromiso de que iba de una revisión
del acuerdo de parís en cinco años este
está justamente en la corte la revisión
del acuerdo de parís por lo tanto hay
mucha presión seguimos esperando los
ciudadanos
más ambición hay una clara intención de
muchos grupos de poder cierto de seguir
tratando de aumentar ese tiempo para la
reconversión
particularmente aquellos que tienen que
ver con la producción petrolera y por lo
tanto va disminuyendo cierto tanto el
accionar como también el paso
pero una cosa importante y yo creo que
hay un modelo también diría yo de
esperanza que es
mucho mucha gente ve el sector privado
como también de la sociedad civil por lo
mismo dado que los gobiernos están tan
lentos entonces también se han lanzado
hacia las calles como también han
entrado en activarse de otra forma en la
empresa privada particularmente muchas
muchas de ellas está haciendo sus
propias cuestiones que están llevando
justamente y que están llevando la
delantera a lo gobierno
marcelo también es de la ciudad de
glasgow porque le cuesta tanto a los
países a los gobiernos poder avanzar con
la implementación de los planes que
estipulan en cada una de las naciones
para hacerle frente a esta problemática
ambiental sobre todo en países que
tienen recursos económicos porque una
cosa es lo que podemos ver en américa
latina donde hay otras prioridades como
la pobreza o los sistemas de salud o
reforzar la educación pero en los países
desarrollados hay recursos para poderlo
hacer porque no se ejecutan yo creo que
el cortoplacismo que tenemos hoy día lo
que mccartney economista el banco
central de inglaterra llamaban la
tragedia del horizonte es decir tomamos
un análisis de móvil de corto plazo
siempre estamos pensando en los próximos
años los próximos meses pero no estamos
haciendo la inversión de largo plazo que
son más rentables
ahora quiero destacar sí y para
latinoamérica nosotros sacamos un
estudio con el centro global de
actuación para una recuperación
económica verde y demostraba de que la
resiliencia que se puede invertir en
latinoamérica es bastante rentable como
inversión solamente gastando un 3% más
uno puede hacer un diseño de estructura
resiliente para empezar a proteger esto
avance del desarrollo que tanto ha
costado que están siempre amenazados en
el caso chile por ejemplo tenemos dos
caminos a elegir o podemos resignar el
27 por ciento no utilice movimiento
económico hacia mediados de siglo o que
es ser un 5 por ciento más crudo de la
descarbonización como resultado de esto
menores costos energía mayor inversión
mayor empleo entonces tenemos que
empezar a tomar esto en serio porque ya
el vídeo otras instituciones como el
banco mundial donde trabaje indican de
que este camino hacia la
descarbonización es el que trae el mayor
costaría aire más limpio más inversión
mayor cantidad de empleo
fundamentalmente de mujeres y por tanto
están las manos de latinoamérica de no
esperar que el resto del mundo actúe
sino que actúe en su propio beneficio y
cuando lo hace va a ser beneficiando
fundamentalmente a la gente más
postergada porque actuar contra el
cambio climático también es actuar
contra la superación de la pobreza y es
actuar contra la desigualdad
marcelo pero entonces de acuerdo al que
usted nos indica si es posible
desarrollar de pronto al mediano plazo
un sistema económico verde partiendo de
la realidad latinoamericana es posible
construirlo un sistema económico
partiendo de lo verde partiendo del
medio ambiente y no solamente de extraer
recursos y estar pensando en la parte
económica
absolutamente bueno de hecho el mitre es
más importante acá hablando
estrictamente lo económico me traje en
el banco mundial era el gerente de
investigación en cambio climático de
nuestros estudios mostraban de que la
acción climática
es algo que genera más empleo bajan los
costos de transporte y energía nos hace
menos vulnerable a esta alza de precio
combustible que estamos viendo hoy día
no hacen menos dependientes la
importación de combustibles fósiles y
por tanto es un camino que tenemos que
seguir y es el mejor interés de los
mismos latinoamericanos que son
altamente vulnerable al cambio climático
estamos con el doble de nuestro activo
dispuestos al daño climático los avances
que tenemos año a año se ven amenazados
constantemente fruto de desastres
naturales en el caso de centroamérica y
el caribe
los huracanes pueden causar que se
pierdan décadas de avance en el caso de
chile y argentina la sequía también es
el talón de aquiles de nuestro
desarrollo el derretimiento de los
glaciares va a poner en jaque el
suministro del agua potable y por tanto
está en interés de nosotros superar este
corto racismo y de superar en la
tentación de querer recuperarse
económicamente ignorando los efectos del
cambio climático sino que aprovechar
esta instancia única que tenemos en esta
década decisiva de transformar esta
amenaza en la oportunidad desarrollo más
rentable y justo para toda la región
maximiliano veíamos en el reportaje al
inicio del programa en la clasificación
en la que están algunos países de la
región y del mundo dependiendo de cómo
han empezado a implementar sus políticas
para hacer mejoras en la parte ambiental
y climate action tracker destaca
solamente en la categoría amarilla de
almost sufficient a costa rica en toda
la región de américa latina
prácticamente del continente la región
no está haciendo lo suficiente estamos
parado con el resto del mundo
muy atrás todavía estamos como en el
promedio con el resto de las naciones
que han hecho poco
yo creo estamos lamentablemente el
promedio del promedio es malo en
problemas
entonces la verdad es que ahí están la
clave ahora efectivamente costa rica da
unos pasos importantísimo y ha dado
damos unos ejemplos importantes también
en términos de electromovilidad y otro
no
yo creo que que hoy día también uno de
los temas clave en el financiamiento y
eso es lo que también está afectando en
parte el avance de alguna de las
políticas obviamente países como en
latinoamérica que necesitan dinero para
poder justamente cambiar ya sea de
fuentes de energía para poder cambiar
cierto la electromovilidad necesitan
financiamiento importante y es sobre los
temas clave que está hoy día todavía sin
finalizar es cierto por varios años ya
la discusión y tener un resultado de
como es cierto los países ricos van a
apoyar a los países en vía de desarrollo
para poder hacer esos cambios que son
necesarios
pero maximiliano no sé si usted conoce
bien el caso de costa rica que políticas
han implementado allí que pueden ser
destacables o que sirvan de ejemplo para
otros países de la región porque es el
que va liderando y tal vez puede ser el
ejemplo a seguir sí correcto de la
descarbonización de la matriz ha sido
una de las claves no
ese soy yo creo que donde llevan la
batuta y donde seguramente obviamente
debiéramos también seguir todos los
países el chile iba en un buen en unos
buenos formatos donde en algún momento y
lamentablemente se ha vuelto alguna de
las energías sucias
de las cuales había prometido
eventualmente deshacerse sin embargo
costa rica ha venido avanzando muy
fuertemente ha tenido una política bien
clara al respecto también a la vez ha
logrado implementar
cuestiones que tienen que ver con cambio
transporte es un país también que tiene
de alguna forma más facilidades en
hacerlo una población mucho más pequeña
aceptó y por lo tanto si uno compara con
algunas de las economías
más grandes como argentina como chile o
brasil etcétera pero sin duda el
esfuerzo que han puesto en ello es
importantísimo y tiene que ser una
cuestión de política el gobierno actual
ha prometido que efectivamente ser un
tema es crucial era vertebral para este
gobierno y lo ha cumplido lo ha sido
avanzando con creces yo creo que me
gustaría y entonces qué es la ambición y
la ambición demostrada también en temas
políticos hoy día cruciales para para la
región voluntad política sería en
resumen
marcelo vemos la otra cara de la moneda
aquí en la región de américa latina
vemos a argentina a brasil colombia
méxico que son algunas de las economías
más grandes de la región de américa
latina en la categoría altamente
insuficiente que yo lo traducía como
altamente vergonzoso que estos países no
estén haciendo muchos esfuerzos para
para poder mejorar sus condiciones
climáticas estos países en qué condición
se encuentran cuál es la perspectiva que
hay sobre ellos en cuanto a sus avances
yo creo que fundamentalmente el problema
que tenía en países como argentina o
venezuela o méxico tiene que ver con su
tentación de subsidiar o
comentar la extracción de combustibles
fósiles cuando los recursos renovables
que tienen estos países son amplios y
han dado fruto por ejemplo argentina con
su proyecto renovar fue capaz de poder
recalar apalancar miles de millones de
dólares de inversión en energía
renovable pero después la tentación a
volver a subsidiar la energía fósil es
grande y por tanto hay retrocesos yo
creo que acá lo importante entender qué
lugar le cabe a cada país dentro del
mundo en su compromiso con la mitigación
climática el caso de brasil es
emblemático un país que quiere recibir
financiamiento internacional pero no
está dispuesto a hacer mucho para
avanzar hoy día bolso el presidente por
salario compromete a descarbonizar el
2050 sin embargo hemos visto lo que ha
pasado con la deforestación del amazonas
y la regla civilización
los impactos de este tipo de incendios
tenemos el caso de argentina como decía
de la vuelta quizás de los subsidios a
los combustibles cuando en regla
práctica deberíamos reconocer el precio
de la contaminación con mayor fuerza yo
creo que podemos hacer mucho más hoy día
el caso de chile por ejemplo estamos
instalando casi tanta energía renovable
este año como la década pasada completa
y la energía que se subasta básicamente
está costando más barato que cualquier
otra fuente de energía del mundo y por
tanto está claro que el caso económico
para poder seguir profundizando en la
revolución energética está hoy día en
acción que actualiza los análisis de lo
que es la estrategia de largo plazo de
chile y le pone como casi suficiente no
hay que dormirse los laureles pero por
lo menos son pasos en la dirección
correcta lo que ocurre es que
lamentablemente el presupuesto 2022 de
chile es con la rebaja en aspectos
mentales y por tanto no se condice en lo
que dice que va a ser para el futuro por
lo que va a ser a la vuelta a la esquina
y esa es la dicotomía que tenemos que
empezar a romper tenemos que actuar hoy
lo que prometimos para mañana eso va en
sintonía con la pregunta que le quería
hacer en marcelo porque hay reducciones
en estas coyunturas porque siempre tiene
que haber incentivos económicos
incentivos financieros por ejemplo el
caso de brasil que está esperando
financiación extranjera cuando el
incentivo es que ya estamos en un punto
crítico a nivel del planeta ya esto
sería más bien un sentido de
conservación de nosotros como sociedad
de humanidad y no estar esperando el
incentivo económico de si me reducen
impuestos entonces yo si algo o algo en
mi industria para poder mejorar el
cambio climático o hacer un pequeño
aporte porque no se desconecta uno del
otro la parte económica
marcelo y yo creo que tienen que ver con
que un cortoplacismo yo creo que el
desconocimiento y alta ideologización
vivir gran parte de la economía del
mundo podrían reconocer mucho mejor la
externalidad negativa que causa el
cambio climático a través de un precio
correcto del carbono lamentablemente él
no tenemos ese precio solamente algunos
contados países de latinoamérica tienen
un peso de la contaminación como
corresponde sólo así se va a poder
competir con igualdad de condiciones con
los suministros de energía vivían en ese
contexto cuando uno incorpora el peso de
la contaminación uno se da cuenta
rápidamente que la energía más barata
del mundo es la energía renovable la
electromovilidad es la vía más para
tratar de transportarse y también hemos
visto eso como funcionado en costa rica
en chile en colombia en paraguay hay
buses eléctricos porque porque cada
kilómetro que recorren ahorrar al
sistema 70% con respecto al diésel y
cuando sube el precio combustible como
está pasando hoy día está mucho menos
vulnerable la economía hacia eso porque
la práctica tenemos un sistema que no es
dependiente de los combustibles fósiles
hay mil buses eléctricos en santiago de
chile se hizo sin ningún subsidio se
hace básicamente porque es más barato y
ese tipo de ecuación tenemos que empezar
a resolver como miramos a largo plazo
quizás no se pagan 12 años pero si se
pagan 5 y eso tenemos que empezar a
decir porque vamos a caer los próximos 5
años espero me pare así también los
próximos 10 y 20 entonces todo esto es
rentable a largo plazo simplemente que
estamos pensando los próximos seis meses
el próximo año lamentablemente los
ciclos políticos solamente piensan en
ese periodo la hacienda prensa el
próximo año y el presidente la república
los cuatro años que va a estar de jefe
de estado lo que tenemos que pensar es
qué hacemos para las futuras
generaciones y hacemos los próximos 20 o
30 años y que el futuro les dejamos me
parece un punto importante maximiliano
quiero también conocer su opinión sobre
estas necesidades que tiene que haber
siempre un incentivo económico
financiero para poder llevar a cabo un
proyecto y ya lo decía yo estamos en un
punto crítico que ya no hay tiempo para
esperar ya el planeta está en un momento
crítico
sí correcto y yo creo que efectivamente
siempre estamos mirando el
financiamiento y la parte económica sin
embargo cierto es evidente que lo que
mejor extraemos del planeta en nuestra
existencia como como bien lo decía nacer
aquí hay una cosa que es mucho más
importante que finalmente la salud de la
humanidad
y hoy día es difícil ponerlo pareciera
hacerla en la mesa sin embargo evidente
que todo lo que viene de lo que ponemos
en nuestras mesas viene del planeta es
cierto la mitad del aire que respiramos
viene del océano etcétera y yo creo que
aquí es importante que nos demos cuenta
también que necesitamos un sistema vivo
completo tenemos una crisis no solamente
del clima sino que también estamos en
crisis y de la biodiversidad que estamos
una crisis global que tenemos que ir
tratarla como tal tenemos que mantener
ecosistemas sanos ecosistemas que son
saludables para mantener a los animales
y a la vida que viven eso que usted ha
problema también algo humano y yo creo
que tengo que empezar justamente a
pensar más de esa forma es que tal
parece que lo que estamos viviendo en
este momento que ya es un ejemplo
evidente del no fuera una terapia de
choque suficiente para la humanidad ya
estamos viendo sequías más frecuentes
inviernos un poco más cortos pero mucho
más intensos temporadas de lluvias
huracanes más fuertes y tal parece que
eso todavía no nos hace en reaccionar
maximiliano continuó con usted y quiero
preguntarle por un participante muy
particular de esta cumbre destacó 26 en
la ciudad de glasgow y es el regreso de
eeuu el presidente yo baiden hay mucha
expectativa en torno a lo que pueda
llegar a eeuu a anunciar allí a comentar
ya el presidente hablaba de su plan de
infraestructura y de muchos cambios y
apuestas
medioambientales que quiere hacer qué
expectativas hay al respecto al papel de
eeuu allí
mucha la verdad es que durante el tiempo
que eeuu no es tu cierto presente se
sufrió con bastante menos ambición el
presidente demostró también es el
presente valle donde mostró cierto su
interés en poner a alguien como john
kerry un diplomático de carrera tras ser
tú una persona que tiene que ama fui
de alguna forma del acuerdo de parís y
por lo tanto demuestra la importancia
que le concede a esta cumbre el mismo y
aunque de hecho en varias oportunidades
que esta es una cumbre particularmente
importante estar probablemente la más
importante porque estamos a punto de
fracasar o de seguir avanzando cierto en
esa en esa ambición para poder lograr
cierto el objetivo que es al menos el
1.5 y recordemos que el 1.5 ya es algo
pasado o sea que ya hay
efectos graves que se nos vienen una vez
que hayamos superado esa barrera y
jonker lo tiene muy claro él ha estado
viajando intensamente por todo el
planeta con el enviado especial de la
casa blanca tienen un arma un rol muy
particular es muy buena coordinación
también con el state department
he tenido la oportunidad de trabajar
bastante con ellos también he visto el
esfuerzo que han puesto en estos meses
realmente es para sacarse el sombrero
pero alguna tarea y es realmente
maratónica importante muchísimo trabajo
por delante para eeuu incluso el
presidente joe biden comenzó pidiendo
disculpas por la política de eeuu en
términos medioambientales dejada por la
administración anterior marcelo continuó
con usted y le preguntó por el otro
jugador importante de esta cumbre y es
china que es tal vez uno de los países
que más contamina que más gases
contaminantes expulsa hacia la atmósfera
y tiene políticas particulares ya ha
dicho que quería hacer una reducción del
consumo de carbono pero ahora debido a
la crisis energética en la que estamos
ha pedido volver al consumo de carbono y
esto ya ha incrementado los números en
este país como ven ustedes allí el
desempeño de china en cuanto a sus
políticas y a sus planes a futuro
y así una amiga en lo que estaba en
juego en la cope 24 a tuviste hace tres
años teníamos eeuu fuera del acuerdo de
parís teníamos ningún país se había
comprometido a una descarbonización
nieta
hacia el 2050 y varios años después tres
años después tenemos a china con un
compromiso de escarbar eso en el año
2060 también aparece estados
unidos-brasil unión europea chile y hoy
día son más de 160 países que han
comprometido una descarbonización meta
en el caso de china un esfuerzo muy
integrado a la descontaminación
atmosférica hay una cosa de su prestigio
que está en juego y hoy día está
avanzando bastante bien en el sentido
que los programas que hacen son
monumentales por ejemplo en la ciudad de
hebei han cambiado más de tres millones
de calefactores por este que ocupaban
antes carbón de contaminar las ciudades
y voy a estar apuntando a combustibles
más limpios tienen un reconocimiento del
precio de la contaminación en su
economía y están impulsando muchísimo
energía y de hecho del presidente
jinping comprometió a no hacer centrales
nuevas en su zona lo que queda como
incuestionable y va a pasar con los
países con las cuales financia chinas
muchas veces que muchas veces se fomenta
el uso de carbón pero ahí yo creo que
hay que tener paciencia con china porque
tiene muy claro la hoja de ruta el país
entiende que están sus intereses más
avanzados entiende que los impactos que
ha sufrido este año han sido profundos
para su economía ustedes vieron las
imágenes de los metros de las
inundaciones en china y eso también pegó
en europa importante yo creo que va a
haber un despertar mayor hacia esto pero
esto no se va a superar si no vamos más
allá de los ciclos políticos de corto
plazo de financiar recuperarse ignorando
los desafíos del cambio climático esa ha
sido la amenaza constante que hemos
tenido a una decisión que sea la
correcta y por tanto yo creo que china
bueno nosotros como norteamericanos son
espectadores vemos que china dice eeuu
fue el mayor emisor histórico y
efectivamente china es el mayor emisor
actual y lo que está claro es que ambos
tienen que tomar medidas de la misma
forma que también la región
y también tener responsabilidad en la
reducción de emisiones no podemos
esperar que otros hagan lo que nosotros
no estamos dispuesto a hacer y no
podemos esperar que otros cuiden a los
niños y nosotros mismos no estamos
haciendo lo suficiente para proteger su
futuro claro me quedan pocos minutos
para terminar el programa y me quedo con
eso que está diciendo marcelo de los
jóvenes y los jóvenes precisamente están
teniendo un papel destacado en esta copa
26 a nivel internacional han sido
consultados están allí presentes ya
conocemos algunos de los movimientos que
hay a nivel internacional del friday for
matters y bueno todos estos movimientos
que hay a nivel internacional sus
impresiones rápidamente marcelo sobre
estos movimientos y la importancia de
los jóvenes
yo creo que ha cambiado en el diálogo yo
creo que nos obligan hoy día había una
joven chilena se llamaba isis riquelme
que hizo un llamado desgarrador hacia
que tomemos acciones al igual que guetta
este hombre en su momento cambio cambio
el diálogo y hoy día se reforman
referente la voz de la juventud tiene
que estar marchando tiene que exigir
estas acciones porque como dice de poner
a la negación no es una política tenemos
que empezar esto a tomarlo ahora cada
elección que se lleva a cabo en todos
lugares del mundo tenemos que exigir que
la autoridades tomen acciones hoy no
mañana no prometan cosas que no pueden
cumplir y yo creo que eso es fundamental
hacia la que estoy muy feliz de estar de
hecho este próximo viernes imagino que
voy a estar con mi amigo max bello
marchando y mirando a la juventud en
este disco de ficción concreta está en
bergara en glasgow
bueno pues allá estarán ustedes dos en
la ciudad de glasgow en escocia haciendo
parte de estos movimientos maximiliano
para el cierre
quiero terminar
preguntándole que nos debe dejar esta
cop 26 seis años después del acuerdo de
parís el regreso de eeuu los compromisos
de china los compromisos de brasil de
india veinte años después india se ha
comprometido a que dejara la completara
la descarbonización veinte años después
de las fechas que muchos países han
estipulado pero bueno hay un compromiso
como lo ve usted quienes debe dejar esta
cumbre
yo creo que la cumbre va a dejar varias
varias cosas importantes no debiera
dejarnos cerrar en la discusión sobre el
financiamiento una de las cuestiones
claves que hemos estado esperando por
mucho tiempo de lo cual algunos países
ha sido particularmente complejo yo creo
que también esperamos que china siga
avanzando de la mano como hacía muy bien
marcelo también con con otras naciones
desarrolladas particularmente con eeuu y
hay un tándem no de negociación y de y
de avance lo máximo posible otra cosa
importante también es recordar que el
océano es parte integral de estas
discusiones como ustedes saben el 70% de
la tierra está cubierta por océano y el
año pasado reciente de un texto
referente a ello y por lo tanto
esperamos que este año también podamos
avanzar en introducir el océano dentro
del acuerdo de parís porque obviamente
la solución es basada en la naturaleza
son claves así como proteger a la
amazona también en mi caso cierto de
brasil y todos los países que lo
comparten también tenemos que pensar en
el océano como una manera clave muchas
cosas que podemos hacer como humanos hay
mucha innovación que es posible pero no
hay nada que pueda hacer tanto como lo
puede hacer la naturaleza misma que
tiene la capacidad impresionante de
secuestrar carbono de producir también
cierto riqueza si lo quieren o llamar
pero sobre todo de producir vida y para
hacerlo marcel diario conclusión tenemos
de dejar estas compañías era un comenta
un comentario también justamente francia
eeuu y chile liberaron lo que se llamaba
picados de hoy en una declaración para
utilizar los océanos como una forma
captura de carbono y reconocerlos dentro
del acuerdo de parís y ayer se celebró
una actualización de esa declaración
esperamos que más países se sumen a la
conservación oceánica me tocó trabajar
con max en hacer la mayor área protegida
marina de latinoamérica que está en rapa
nui y creo que tenemos que seguir
avanzando mucho más porque nuestros
ecosistemas costeros están bajo amenaza
hoy estaba una crisis de pérdida de
diversidad si estamos haciendo muchas
veces reuniones el por forma remota
tiene que ver con que estamos una crisis
una pandemia que tiene que ver con
nuestra expansión la pérdida de hábitat
y por tanto estamos vulnerables este
tipo de y el colapso ecológico puede ser
algo que puede ser incluso más profundo
de lo que es el cambio climático así que
está en nuestra mano ese futuro lo
importante es votar y exigir que cada
una estas elecciones se apunten a
autoridades que estén tomando esto el
centro sus discusiones pues como lo
decíamos al inicio del programa 26 es
ahora o nunca es una de las últimas
oportunidades que tenemos para instaurar
políticas que lleven a mejorar las
condiciones climáticas y ambientales que
estamos viviendo en este momento a
marcelo mena ya maximiliano bello les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros se han compartido con nosotros
sus puntos de vista y opiniones en torno
a este tema ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y sus preguntas
a través de las redes sociales de france
24 también los invito para que sigan
viendo nuestra programación siga con
nosotros
[Música]